anxiety attacks are sometimes
interpreted by society at large but also
by their confused guilty or shamed
sufferance as an illness close to
madness the result of her mysteriously
chemically based floor in the brain that
severs us from the reality of normality
the suggested treatment is therefore
medical involving forceful attempts to
dampen and anesthetize parts of the
misfiring mind yet such an
interpretation however kind in its
intentions depends on one assumption
that the normal response to the
conditions of existence should be calm
but why should it be given the obvious
insanity of the world the root cause of
an anxiety attack is just unusual
sensitivity to a madness in the world
that most people dampen out of course
once you think about it it's entirely
understandable that one might have an
anxiety attack at a party when talking
to a colleague or on a crowded train
there is genuine terror beneath the
surface or such things in her great
novel Middlemarch the 19th century
English writer George Eliot a deeply
self-aware but also painfully
self-conscious and anxious figure
reflected on what it would be like if we
were truly sensitive open to the world
and felt the implications of everything
if we had a clear vision and feeling of
all ordinary life it would be like
hearing the grass grow and the squirrels
heartbeat and we should die of that
royal which lies on the other side of
silence as it is the quickest of us walk
about well watered with stupidity
it is as Elliot recognizes both
privilege and a profound nightmare to
hear that grass growing and that
squirrels heart beating and also by
extension to feel everything so deeply
we might well as she sometimes did long
for a little more well what is stupidity
to block it all out nevertheless Eliot's
lines offer us a way to reinterpret our
anxiety with greater dignity and
benevolence our anxiety attacks emerge
from a dose of clarity that is currently
too powerful for us to cope with but
isn't for that matter wrong we panic
because we right root for a firm the
veneer of civilization is how mysterious
other people are how improbable it is
that we exist at all and how everything
that seems to matter now will eventually
be annihilated how random any of the
turnings of our lives are how prey we
are to accident anxiety is simply
insight that we haven't yet found a
productive useful that hasn't yet made
its way into art or philosophy it's a
mad world that insists that the anxious
are the crazy ones we are in such a
hurry to see anxiety as a sickness we
fail to notice its health and almost
distinctive wisdom it is a legitimate
response to the oddity of going to
parties riding public transport or more
widely of being alive we should never
exacerbate our suffering by trying to
push our disquiet aggressively away our
anxiety isn't deplorable or a sign of
weakness it's simply the justifiable
expression of our mysterious
participation in a disordered and
uncertain world we publish new
thought-provoking films every week be
sure to subscribe to our Channel and
take a look at more of what we have to
offer at the link on your screen now
you